I want Jesus to be glorified. So it
doesn't have to be me. Amen. Let me let
me repeat, Alex. You want me, please.
But if you want him, glory to God, cuz
I'm
being honest before the Lord. He's going
to call me account. Yep. It's not about
me debating you. If William debates you,
I know he's going to pulverize your
objections. I want Jesus to be
glorified. And that's all that matters,
man. Seriously. Praise the Lord. Amen,
brother. That's the whole thing. Giving
glory to God. That is the whole thing.
and giving glory to God. Yeah, let's do
this. That concludes Alex's second
rebuttal round. We're going to move to
open discussion. All right. All right.
All right.
Well, shall we spark it off, gentlemen?
Whatever you like. Let's do it. Open
dialogue. Who would like to take the
lead? Uh, well, I have some questions
perhaps to ask David about his position
on Jesus's relationship to the father
with particular regards to the authority
that he derives from the the father. So
one question for example, why do you
think that Jesus
prays before raising Lazarus from the
dead?
Um the the Old Testament says that God
is the God of all flesh. If um if a
divine being were to become incarnate as
is claimed of Jesus and that divine
being really became a flesh and blood
human being like Jesus then um if he
is if he's also had an eternal
relationship with the
father then I I don't know if I'd expect
him to be an atheist when he entered
into creation. So I in other words in
other words if if if the Christian
picture is correct, you've got father
and son for all eternity, son enters
into creation. Um what's he going to be?
An atheist if he is going to as uh as
part of it is if he's going to be the
ideal human or something like that.
Yeah. And so the son of man, one might
say, as far as uh as far as what Jesus
is going to do, um you would continue
the eternal relationship that you've had
with the father and you would do that
through prayer. So what I mean to say is
could Jesus have have risen Lazarus from
the dead of his own accord on his own
authority?
I suppose. Yeah, I suppose. Cuz let's
deal with this one first, brother. I
think this one will be valuable to deal
with first I suppose so when I hear
David give these responses first of all
not to belabor the point the argument
that what would you expect Jesus to be
an atheist the reason why I cringe
that's a James White argument I'm not
attacking him if you go back and watch
James White's arguments he goes what do
you expect Jesus to be an atheist when
they say why does Jesus call the father
the only true
Yes, we agree. If Jesus is not the only
person of God and he becomes human and
he's the perfect human, man is God
intends man to be then he can't be an
atheist. But that's besides the point.
Completely besides that's not the
argument from what I understand Alex was
making. Right. That wasn't his argument.
You are correct. Yep. He was not saying
why does Jesus pray. saying, "Why is he
praying to raise Lazarus?" That's
correct. Yep. That's the argument,
right? Right. Because the debate is, is
he God? Is he almighty God in essence?
So, Alex believes that this is a knock
against whether or not he's almighty
God. So, yes, you're 100% correct. Okay.
So, I just want to make sure I'm
representing Alex correctly. The
argument is if he's God, why is he
needing to pray to the father to raise
Lazarus? That's correct. Yep. I'm not
going to screen share if I can because
we're going to bring up the scriptures.
Yes, definitely, brother. Yes. All
right. Number one, let's break this
down. We're going to break down. Why did
Jesus pray? Had David simply taken him
to the text. Just take him to the text,
you'll see what Jesus is saying. Now,
let's break it down. And brethren, I
promise you by the Holy Spirit, I would
be doing this on the fly right there in
front of Alex. That's correct. With
William, I'm not boasting. I'm boasting
in the Lord. Let's see the prayer to
understand why Jesus prayed. Number one,
here it is. Y I'm using New
International Version, the nearly
inspired version. All right, guys. Let's
see why Jesus prayed. So they took away
the stone. Then Jesus looked up and
said, "Father, I thank you that you have
heard me. I knew that you always hear
me, but I said this for the benefit of
the people standing here that they may
believe that you sent me." Right there.
the reason why I am praying. So, number
one, they will know Jesus is not the
father. Remember, we're trinitarians.
When we say Jesus is God, we're not
saying he's the only person who's God.
Number one, he's not the father. Number
two, he's the father's son, authorized
by the father to do and say what he
does. Number three, when he raises
Lazarus from the dead, that will be the
miracle to confirm the father sent me.
I'm inseparable from the father in
perfect union with the father. And the
father approves of everything I do
because whatever I do, he delights in.
Yep. In other words, this is the
father's way of saying, "Amen to my son.
Whatever my son says, take him at his
word because I'm confirming he's
speaking the truth. Well, what truth did
Jesus say that the father gave his amen
to? Let's just go a little earlier, but
let me finish. It's right there in the
context. Let me just finish this. When
he had said this, Jesus called in a loud
voice, Lazarus, come out. The dead man
came out, his hands and feet wrapped
with strips of linen and the cloth
around his face. Jesus said to them,
"Take off the grave clothes and let him
go." So now notice, when Christ raises
him, that's the father showing by the
miracle that Jesus did. Amen to my son.
He's not lying to you. He's my son, sent
by me, authorized by me to say and do
what he does. And I am amening
everything he says as gospel truth.
Well, that means the father amened this.
Yes, that's what John 11 25- 26. The
father amened this. Jesus said to her, I
am the resurrection life. And what did
the father say? Amen. You, my son, are
indeed the resurrection life. Amen. The
one who believes in me will live even
though they die and ever lives. By
believing in me will never die. Do you
believe this? And the father is saying,
"Amen. My son is indeed the resurrection
life. Take him at his word. Don't doubt
him." That's the first response. The
second response, he said, "Could Jesus
do what?" Again on his what? I just want
to make sure I remembered it. What do
you mean? Raise the dead on his own
accord.
This again shows now I don't expect Alex
to understand the trinity but I expect
David to ask any Catholic who knows the
trinity. William knows the trinity. Even
Orthodox that knows the trinity. There
is no trinitarian who thinks the son
acts
independently apart from the father on
his own accord. Our belief and I'm going
to prove it from John. Yep. The father
and son and spirit always act in perfect
union in inseparable union. They never
act independently because the father's
authority is the son's authority is the
spirit's authority because if it was
otherwise that would make them three
separate gods. Yep. Now let me prove it
from John. No. The son does nothing on
his own accord authority because the
father's authority is his authority. the
spirit's authority because they're one
God who work inseparably. Yep. And here
Jesus says that about himself and the
Holy Spirit. Right there in John. Yep.
You're going right where I was going to
go. Yep. And let me show you even from
the Holy Spirit. Yep. So, no, there is
no such thing as the son doing his own
thing on his own authority or the
spirit. That's not the trinity. That's
not one God because we derive the
trinity from what the Bible teaches
here. just to prove my assertions from
the same gospel of John.
And I've got to say, brother, very
briefly, let me just say very briefly,
to me, this shows that Alys Connor does
not understand the trinity. He doesn't
understand what we believe about the
trinity because he did, he would know
that there's not a trinitarian alive
that is going to argue that any, whether
it be father, son, or holy spirit act
independently. We don't argue that they
are in perfect unity. And Christ acts
with divine authority, but he never acts
apart from the father or the spirit.
That's trinity theology 101, brother.
Yeah, but brother, I don't expect
Okconor to know. Why didn't David know?
Yeah, because he doesn't know his faith
like he should. And he's lost in the
wilderness of
Protestantism. Let me read the evidence
for what we just said. Here you go.
Black and white. John 5:1 19-21. Jesus
gave them this answer. Very truly I tell
you, the son can do nothing by himself.
David, Jesus answered it for you right
here, brother. The gospel of John, man,
he can do only what he sees his father
doing because whatever the father does,
the son also does. Now, no creature can
say this. Let me explain. No creature
can say, "I only do what God does."
Creatures do a lot of things that God
wouldn't do. Secondly, no creature can
say I can do whatever God does in the
way that God does it because that would
mean you would have to have the
power that God has. So you'll never find
Old Testament or an apostle in the New
Testament saying I can only do what God
does. Yeah, here's the son saying, "I
cannot act independently from the
father, only in perfect union to affirm
he's not a renegade deity, and I do
whatever he does and the way he does
it." For example, for the father loves
the son and shows him all he does. Yes,
he will show him even greater works than
these so that you will be amazed. For
just as the father raises the dead and
gives them life, even so the son gives
life to whom he is pleased to give it.
So notice, like the father, the son
gives life. Like the father, the son
raises the dead. And the son says he is
the resurrection life. Something never
ascribed to anyone other than God in the
Hebrew Bible. Finally, what about the
Holy Spirit? That's the word
trinitarian. Same thing said about the
Holy Spirit. John
16:12-13 I have much more to say to you
more than you can now bear but when he
the spirit of truth comes he will guide
you into all the truth he will not speak
on his own see the trinity they don't
act independently they don't act on
their own accord always in perfect
inseparable unity he will speak only
what he hears and he will tell you what
is to come see how easy it is to refute
Alex Connor Yep. And that's a brilliant
point, brother. As we pointed out and as
you pointed out over and over, um
there's not a trinitarian alive, whether
they be Catholic, Orthodox, Protestant,
uh that believes that they acted
independently. They don't. John 5:19 is
perfect. Another one that's great, and
you've brought it up many times, John uh
John 14:10, the father who dwells in me
does his works. Christ isn't the lone
operator. The father works in and
through him. That's trinitarian theology
101. Another one that I love that shows
you the involvement of the spirit in the
ministry of Christ. Acts 10:38, God
anointed Jesus of Nazareth with the Holy
Spirit and with power. He went about
doing good and healing all. The spirit
is involved in the ministry of Christ.
They work together. You don't separate
them. Christ is not a lone operator. So
to me it baffles me how Alice Okconor
believes these are even relatively
remotely good arguments. They're not
good arguments. Rather to me it shows me
he doesn't understand the doctrine of
the trinity. And I would expect that
from a non-believer. But yet again, I
have to echo your sentiments in the
world of Protestantism where you lack
this systematic theology you find in the
apostolic churches at times dealing with
things that are trinitarian in matter
and christoologgical in matter where you
also do deep dives into the fathers is
very much lacking in the world of
Protestantism.
You see why I say William is much more
gracious. I pray I can be like him. He's
trying in his love not to criticize
David. You're a good man, brother. Pride
can be like you because you're saying
look Alex we are but remember brethren
why I'm now going to hold David
accountable because he will be judged
more strictly. The more you know the
greater your judgment. I'll be judged
more strictly. Alex is an atheist. I
don't expect him to know the trinity and
its
intricacies. David has no excuse. You